Hey, hey, we're rolling. Do I have speed? Yeah, we got speed, Sean, were you going to say something you were holding about? I just say it's anybody thirsty. I got some water. Yeah, well, we how can we? None of us can enjoy it. You can hear it. So maybe it'll do the same thing as charging it real quick. See, can you gargle right now and say welcome to SmartList in a gargle. Wow. Wow. Oh my god, this is got to be all over. It's got to get the towel. Welcome to SmartList. SmartList. SmartList.
嘿，嘿，我们在录了。我声音正常吗？对，声音正常，肖恩，你刚才是不是想说你憋着的事？我只是想说有人口渴吗？我有一些水。好吧，我们怎么能？我们谁也无法享受它。你能听到它。所以也许它会起到和快速充电一样的作用。听着，你现在能用漱口的方式说一句“欢迎来到 SmartList”吗？哇。哇。天哪，这肯定全传开了。得拿条毛巾来。欢迎来到 SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。
SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList.
SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。
SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. Hey smart listeners, before we get into the good stuff, how about a little great stuff from Shawnee Hayes? Go Shawnee. Hey smart listeners, this episode is brought to you in part by our friends at Verizon.
SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。嘿，聪明的听众们，在我们进入精彩内容之前，先听肖尼·海斯（Shawnee Hayes）带来的精彩广告怎么样？上吧，肖尼。嘿，聪明的听众们，本集部分内容由我们 Verizon 的朋友赞助播出。
If you're wishing for the new iPhone 15 Pro with titanium, you don't need to find a genie in a bottle, or I don't know, steal an unsuspecting kid's birthday wish. I get it. Verizon is making it easy to get Apple's latest and greatest with an amazing trade-in offer. Even if your current iPhone is seen better days, Sean. Me, my phone is pristine, but you know some of us
如果你一直渴望拥有钛金属材质的全新 iPhone 15 Pro，你不需要去神灯里找精灵，或者我不知道，去偷一个毫无防备的孩子生日愿望。我懂的。Verizon 正通过超值的以旧换新优惠，让你轻松拥有苹果最新、最棒的产品。即使你现在的 iPhone 已经大不如前了，肖恩。我，我的手机完好如初，但你知道我们有些人
just aren't as careful. No judgment here. And look, you know Sean and I are well acquainted with the excellent service and offerings from Verizon, so believe me when I say, this upgrade deal is one for the books. Trade in any iPhone, any model, any condition, for the new iPhone 15 Pro with titanium with unlimited ultimate plan, 100% guaranteed, only on Verizon, a network you can rely on. Visit a Verizon store or Verizon.com for full details. Ofference October 18th, 2023, and is only available in the United States.
就是没那么小心。这里不予评判。听着，你知道肖恩和我对 Verizon 卓越的服务和产品非常熟悉，所以相信我，这次的升级优惠绝对是史无前例的。用任何 iPhone（任何型号、任何状况）以旧换新，即可搭配无限畅享终极套餐（Unlimited Ultimate plan）获得全新钛金属 iPhone 15 Pro，100% 有保障，仅在 Verizon——一个你可以信赖的网络。访问 Verizon 门店或 Verizon.com 了解完整详情。优惠截至 2023 年 10 月 18 日，仅限美国地区。
Now, onto the show. Wait, Sean's back in LA now? Yes. Ah, since when? Last night. Or yes, since last night. or yesterday last night pay attention Oh, Sean, I knew it was soon. I knew it was soon, but I know I'm so excited Sean How does it feel baby angels come back to the nest?
现在，进入正题。等等，肖恩现在回洛杉矶了吗？是的。啊，从什么时候开始？昨晚。或者是的，从昨晚开始。或者昨天晚上，注意听。哦，肖恩，我知道很快。我知道很快，但我知道我太兴奋了，肖恩。感觉怎么样，宝贝天使回到巢穴了？
Baby there are there's no such thing as baby angels and then they grow up and get old Baby angel Baby angel will said to me last week you guys you know you're gonna get sick And it said what yeah, you're gonna get sick. And it said, what? Yeah, you're gonna get sick. Yeah, right when you get home, you'll get sick. And I'm like, why would you think that? And boy, I don't feel sick, but oh my God.
宝贝，根本没有什么宝贝天使，然后他们长大变老。宝贝天使。宝贝天使上周对我说，你们，你知道的，你们会生病的。然后我说，什么？对，你们会生病。然后我说，什么？对，你们会生病。对，就在你到家的时候，你会生病的。我说，你为什么会这么想？天哪，我不觉得生病，但是哦天哪。
Sean, my body doesn't know it's not over. No. So you're going to probably just power down for about a week? No, just a couple days. Sean, you've been up here. You have been working at this high level every day, getting yourself up to this thing every day
肖恩，我的身体还不知道巡演已经结束了。没有。所以你大概会关机一周左右？不，就几天。肖恩，你一直在这里。你每天都在这种高水平下工作，每天都让自己振作起来面对这一切
for months and months and months and months. Is it possible that your body, like you're right, because I told myself I'm not going to get sick. I'm not going to get sick. I can't get sick. And then now I'm just like shutting down my body. It's like, yeah, I'm shutting down too. Yeah. I don't know. Yeah, and what about just what about just your instinct to perform and entertain and and be charismatic and
几个月又几个月又几个月又几个月。有没有可能你的身体——就像你说得对，因为我告诉自己我不会生病。我不会生病。我不能生病。然后现在我只是在关闭我的身体。它就像是，是的，我也在关闭。是的。我不知道。是的，还有仅仅是——仅仅是你表演、娱乐、充满魅力和
Have presence and what not like why start now. Yeah, yeah, you just sit on the couch and Scottie's like Trying to have a conversation and you're just like no not until no talk I'll talk to her. No, no talky-talky anymore. I saw this interview, I'm all bits aside with Miley Cyrus the other day and she was talking about how hard it is, how she doesn't like to tour because she creates this, it's too demanding, it creates this sort of bloated ego because she has to get ready to get up and then her relationship with the audience is being the observed and then the audience is the observer. And what she has to do to create that, she says it pulls her away from her self, her true self, and she becomes something else,
展现气场之类的本能呢，为什么现在要开始这样？是的，是的，你只是坐在沙发上，斯科蒂（Scottie）试图和你对话，而你却只是说，不，直到——不，不说话。我不再聊天了。我看到了这个采访，抛开所有段子不谈，前几天麦莉·赛勒斯（Miley Cyrus）在谈论这有多难，她为什么不喜欢巡演，因为她创造了这种——这要求太高了，这会产生一种臃肿的自我，因为她不得不准备好登台，然后她与观众的关系变成了“被观察者”，而观众则是“观察者”。而她为了创造这种状态所必须做的事情，她说这把她从自己、从她真正的自我中拉开了，她变成了另一个人，
and the more she does it, I mean, I'm kind of... Yeah, makes sense. Paraphrasing. But it made a lot of sense, and I get that, Sean, every night you're up there. Yeah, that was a lot. But it was very rewarding. I'm sad and glad at the exact same time that it's over.
而且她做得越多，我的意思是，我有点……是的，有道理。在用我自己的话说。但这非常合乎情理，我懂的，肖恩，你每天晚上都在那里。是的，那确实挺沉重的。但它也非常有意义。它结束了，我感到既难过又高兴，就在同一时间。
I get to see you guys in real excited whether you guys like it or not. Well, I hope that you're giving yourself the adaboy that you deserve and feeling a sense of pride and accomplishment. Yeah, thanks. And I mean, the accolades are public, so it's unanimous.
无论你们喜欢与否，我又能见到你们了，真的很兴奋。嗯，我希望你给自己应得的表扬，并感受到一种自豪感和成就感。是的，谢谢。我的意思是，赞誉是公开的，所以这是全票通过的。
But also just sort of privately and internally over there at the show, I'm sure that you were also like Tony Award level leader and creating a nice environment and you should pat yourself on the back for all. Well, thanks, that was easy, everybody was great. Well, here's what Sean said to me the other day, which I really related to, and he said, you would love the bits that we do backstage.
但同时，在演出现场私下里和内部，我确信你也像托尼奖级别的领袖一样，创造了一个美好的环境，你应该为这一切拍拍自己的背。嗯，谢谢，这很简单，每个人都很棒。嗯，这是肖恩前几天对我说的话，我深有同感，他说，你会喜欢我们在后台排练的段子。
Non-stop. He's like, I do it almost just for that, and I totally get that, Jay, you know that feeling of like, just being there and fucking around in the bits, we used to have that on a thing that we used to do years ago, and we've all had it, we've shared it together. It's the bits, it's the fucking around. It's the crew you work with and the cast you work with.
没完没了的。他说，我几乎就是为了这个才做的，我完全理解那种感觉，杰伊，你知道那种感觉——就在那里瞎胡闹、抛梗，我们以前在多年前做的一个节目里也有过这种经历，我们都有过，我们一起分享过。这就是段子，这就是胡闹。这就是与你共事的剧组和演员。
And then the product you push out to the public that you never meet is fantastic, but it is a very intimate process, right? Yeah, I used to do this bit right before I entered in the show where there's a little platform where the door is, you know need to step up on the platform. And I pretended I lost all my faculties, like five seconds for entered. And I took both my hands and lifted one leg out of the platform and the other a plate.
然后你向从未谋面的公众推出的产品虽然很棒，但这确实是一个非常私密的过程，对吧？是的，我在上场前会做一个段子，门旁边有一个小平台，你知道，需要踏上那个平台。我假装失去了所有的功能，就像上场前五秒钟那样。我用双手把一条腿抬离平台，另一条也一样。
Then I lifted my arm onto the door handle. And then my cue was like right there. And then you come out, give us a few. Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum. Yeah. I tell you what though, I I'm really excited speaking of bits to get into our guest today because he has so many bits to his life that each one of them individually kind of add up to this incredible, each one of them is incredible unto itself. And then when you look at it, what
然后我把胳膊搭在门把手上。然后我的 cue 点就在那儿。然后你出来，给我们来几个。砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。好吧，我告诉你，说起段子，我真的很兴奋能请到我们今天的嘉宾，因为他的人生中有太多的段子，其中每一个单独拿出来都有点汇聚成这不可思议的——每一个本身都不可思议。然后当你审视他所做的一切
he's done in its entirety, it's truly, it's epic. I don't want to embarrass them. All the bits put together, you know? Yeah. And I don't want to embarrass them. I've never met him. And I'm in awe of the fact that he's here today. He's a musical and an American icon for lack of a better word. We've listened to, here's one of the most amazing things. He sold millions and millions, over a hundred millions of records as a part of a band. And the same amount as a solar recording artist
的全部时，它真的是，它是史诗级的。我不想让他难堪。所有的段子加在一起，你知道的？是的。我不想让他难堪。我从未见过他。我对今天他能来到这里感到敬畏。如果不用一个更好的词来形容，他是一个音乐和美国的偶像。我们听过——这里有一个最神奇的事情。作为乐队成员，他卖出了数百万、数千万，超过一亿张唱片。作为独唱艺人，他也卖出了同样的数量
for the last 50 years. And he's done, he's sung, incredible songs that you know that are such a part of your life at different stages that are part of your parents' lives. Yeah, you know that are such a part of your life at different stages that are part of your parents' lives. Yeah, you know what Jason? Is it Paul Simon? It's just Paul Fredrick Simon, yes.
在过去的 50 年里。他创作并演唱了令人难以置信的歌曲，你知道这些歌曲深深融入了你不同人生阶段的生活，也融入了你父母的生活。是的，你知道这些歌曲深深融入了你不同人生阶段的生活，也融入了你父母的生活。是的，你知道吗，杰森？是保罗·西蒙吗？正是保罗·弗雷德里克·西蒙（Paul Fredrick Simon），是的。
You know what I'm saying, are you kidding me? Shit. There he is. Oh my God. Wow. Wow. What are we doing? I don't know, this is, you know.
你知道我在说什么吗，你在开玩笑吗？靠。他来了。哦，天哪。哇。哇。我们在干什么？我不知道，这，你知道的。
You don't deserve this. I know. Good morning. Good morning. Paul, when I was, this is like so stupid, and you get this every day of your life. But when I was a kid, I listened to two albums over and over and over and over again.
你配不上这个。我知道。早上好。早上好。保罗，当我还是个——这听起来太蠢了，你生活中每天都会听到这个。但当我还是个孩子的时候，我一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地听着两张专辑。
Yours was, the bridge over, the troubled water was one, I memorized. And that's when they had the lyrics on the jacket. And so I memorized all the words to every song, baby driver, like all those songs, and then not cracker, but that's neither here nor there. But I memorized every single word. I've just been, it's wild to meet somebody.
你的是，其中一张是《Bridge Over Troubled Water》（恶水上的大桥），我都背下来了。那时歌词印在唱片封套上。所以我把每首歌的歌词都背了下来，比如《Baby Driver》，所有这些歌，然后不是饼干（cracker），但这跟这无关。但我背住了每一个字。我只是觉得——能见到一个人，这种感觉太疯狂了。
I've never met you. Whereas we talked about this before on the show, where music is actually something that penetrates a person's soul and DNA, and it stays with you forever. And you're one of them for me. It's pretty wild. I know the feeling because we toured with the Everly Brothers once and I had the same feeling
我从来没见过你。正如我们以前在节目中讨论过的，音乐实际上是一种能够深入人的灵魂和DNA的东西，它会永远伴随着你。对我来说，你就是其中之一。这真的挺疯狂的。我懂这种感觉，因为我们曾与埃弗利兄弟（Everly Brothers）同台巡演，我对埃弗利兄弟也有过这种感觉
about the Everly Brothers. I couldn't believe that the Everly Brothers were actually in our show, you know, and they were completely oblivious to how important the figures they were in my life. But you know what about music? It's not, of course it's true that it penetrates deeply and we all have this powerful, powerful memories enhanced by music. But isn't it also so that it's like somewhere really at its zenith between like 12 and 16 years old? The stuff that you hear then maybe a little earlier even.
我简直不敢相信埃弗利兄弟居然出现在我们的演出中，你知道的，而他们完全没有意识到自己在我的生命中是多么重要的人物。但你知道音乐是怎么回事吗？它不是——当然，它能深入人心，这是真的，我们所有人都有这种由音乐增强的强烈而深刻的记忆。但它是不是也在很大程度上处于它真正的巅峰时期，比如在 12 岁到 16 岁之间？你那时候听的东西，也许甚至更早一点。
That is what you love for your whole life. And so it must be that there's something really intense about our senses in that age. I guess that's not a revelation to it. It is a revelation. Well, it's not, but it does seem like those are the years in which you open up and you grow up, and you start to kind of come alive and have a sense of yourself that separate from your identity as a child of your parents. You have an identity.
那才是你一生都在热爱的东西。所以一定是因为我们在那个年龄的感官有着某种非常强烈的东西。我想这也不是什么灵光一现。这确实是个启发。嗯，它不是，但那些年似乎确实是你敞开心扉、长大成人、开始变得有生气、并开始产生一种独立于父母孩子的身份之外的自我意识的时期。你拥有了属于自己的身份。
You start to under, you start to see the world, I think, through different eyes a little bit, 12 through 16, right? And yeah, so all those things hit and Sean, I'm with you. Like I, as I was sort of in anticipation of talking to you today, I went back and I've been listening to so much of your music over the last few days. And it once again kind of, it took me back to very vivid places
我认为，从 12 岁到 16 岁，你开始理解、开始用不同的眼光看待世界，对吧？是的，所以所有这些都冲击着心灵，肖恩，我和你一样。就像我，在期待今天能和你对话时，我回过头去，在过去的几天里一直在听你的很多音乐。它再一次把我带回了那些非常生动的时空
in time, riding in the car with my dad, you know, just being a kid and it makes me emotional now even thinking about it because I can feel that connection. And that must be to be, and I said, for you to say that you had that same feeling with the Everly Brothers is amazing. I guess the question I have for you is, do you, when people come and say these things to you and talk about the importance or where you fit into their lives, their lives? What kind of, what is that relationship like for you? What does that do to you as a person? You know, I don't, I understand it, of course, because as I said, I felt it myself, but as far as thinking about myself in the way that others think about me, I don't think that way.
坐在爸爸的车里，你知道的，仅仅作为小孩子的时光，现在光是想想都让我情绪激动，因为我能感受到那种连接。对于你来说，能说出你对埃弗利兄弟也有过同样的感觉，这太令人惊叹了。我想我问你的问题是，当人们来对你诉说这些、谈论你的重要性或者你在他们生活中的地位时，你有什么感觉？那种关系对你来说是怎样的？这作为一个人对你有什么影响？你知道的，我并不——我当然理解，因为正如我所说，我自己也感受过，但就以别人看我的方式来审视自己而言，我不会那样想。
I don't find it helpful. It's a distraction to think, oh, I, whatever. It's like you were talking about Miley Cyrus before I revealed myself. And is that in the show? What you were talking about, always. Yeah, yeah. It was. Yeah, yeah.
我觉得这对我没有什么帮助。去想“哦，我，不管怎样”这是一种分心。就像你在我表明身份之前谈到麦莉·赛勒斯那样。那是演出里的事吗？你刚才谈论的，一直都是。是的，是的。就是那样。是的，是的。
Yeah. And she was talking about, you were talking about her, thinking about her relationship to the audience. I don't think about that because I find it a distraction to be in the audience at the same time as I'm on the stage. So I think when I'm performing, I'm just interested in listening to what other musicians are playing around me and fitting in in the most musical way that gives me the most pleasure and interpreting the songs that I choose to sing from my repertoire
是的。她在谈论——你当时在谈论她对观众的态度的看法。我不会去想这个，因为我觉得当我身处舞台时，同时又去关注观众会让我分心。所以我想当我表演时，我只关心听周围其他音乐家在演奏什么，并以最让我感到愉悦、最具音乐性的方式融入其中，去诠释我从我的曲目中选择演唱的歌曲，
in a way that makes them still be accurate or relevant to my life because I'm sure you'll all understand this. Once you have to say a line many times and for a singer, if I'm going to sing the sound of silence again, I have to have a reason to sing that or I'm just a Paul Simon cover band. So what's the good at that? Does that mean like, if you were to perform Sound of Silence, let's say tonight, you would look to sort of channel a current feeling that you have, or something that you're thinking about in your life currently, and apply that to the song, and give that the context of the song and the lyrics as you sing it. Maybe if that would work or it depends as long as you're concentrating, if I concentrate on the interpretation of the song,
这种诠释方式要让它们对我的生活依然准确或具有相关性——因为我相信你们所有人都能理解这一点。一旦你必须把一句歌词重复很多遍，对于一个歌手来说，如果我要再次演唱《The Sound of Silence》（寂静之声），我必须有一个去唱它的理由，否则我只是一个保罗·西蒙模仿乐队。那有什么意义呢？这是否意味着，如果你今天要表演《寂静之声》，你会试着去调动你当前的一种感受，或者你目前生活中正在思考的事情，并把它应用到这首歌中，在你演唱时赋予这首歌和歌词相应的背景？也许如果行得通的话，或者这取决于——只要你集中注意力，如果我专注于对这首歌的诠释、
the phrasing, it's almost, I don't know, I don't want to go into, fall into a cliche, but I am about to. It's almost like a little bit of a Zen exercise. You have to find something to concentrate on so that you're not doing it by a rote. And then it's of no value. And I also believe that the audience wants to see you do that. They really don't wants to see you do that. Yeah. They really don't want to see you do the same performance by memory. They won't, and I think that they can sense whether you're doing it sincerely, whatever
对咬字的把握，它几乎是——我不知道，我不想陷入陈词滥调，但我马上就要说了。这几乎就像是一次小小的禅修练习。你必须找到可以专注的东西，这样才不是机械地照本宣科。否则就没有任何价值了。而且我也相信观众希望看到你这样做。他们真的不希望看到你这样做。是的。他们真的不想看到你靠记忆重复同样的表演。他们不会的，而且我认为他们能感觉到你是否是真诚的，无论这种真诚基于什么，还是你只是在应付。他们想看到你感受到它，就像他们在感受它一样。
the sincerity is based on, or whether you're doing it is. They want to see you feel it like they're feeling it. Yeah, you, and then, well, I always say this too about songs, the listener completes the song. I write a song, you hear it, you heard the bridge over Troma Water album and what was the song you picked out? You said Baby Driver? Baby Driver. So that's interesting. So here's a whole album.
是的，你，然后——好吧，我也经常这样谈论歌曲，听众完成了这首歌。我写了一首歌，你听到了，你听了《Bridge Over Troubled Water》专辑，你挑了哪首歌？你说是《Baby Driver》？《Baby Driver》。这很有意思。所以这是一整张专辑。
It was the album of the year and bridge over trouble water. The song was the most popular song in the world that year. But what you remembered was baby driver, which is interesting, because when we made the album, we weren't thinking that Baby Driver was, I wasn't thinking that Baby Driver was going to be, I didn't know what it was going to be. I'm not surprised that you picked that or any other one. And the same goes if I said, well, what's the lyrics of Baby Driver? Well, I will, I will say that to you. What's just going to be an example of the lyrics. And they call them, Baby Driver. Just at the road and I'm going. Okay, good. Let's stop. Sorry. They don't, you know, it was a group. I hit the road and I'm gone. One more than a lot to Sean. It was a really good performance. That's what
它是年度专辑，而《Bridge Over Troubled Water》是那一年世界上最受欢迎的歌。但你记住的是《Baby Driver》，这很有趣，因为当我们制作这张专辑时，我们并没有觉得《Baby Driver》是——我当时并不认为《Baby Driver》会成为——我不知道它会是什么。你挑中这首或任何其他歌，我都不觉得奇怪。如果我说，“《Baby Driver》的歌词是什么？”情况也一样。好吧，我会对你说的。举个歌词的例子。他们叫它，Baby Driver。就开上路，我这就出发。好吧，很好。停。抱歉。他们不——你知道，那是一个乐队。我踏上路途，我已离去。比对肖恩意义重大。这是一次非常精彩的表演。这就是
I'm going to take from this show, your performance. But what you said, Sean was, and they called them baby driver. And they called her or him or something. They called me baby driver. But you remember it as, and they called them baby driver. So, which is just as interesting a lion actually. Yeah. Sean, you were saying yesterday that you love you you loved his the song Sound of Quiet. The sound of Quiet. But by the way, it should be known. I just have to while we're on the Sound of Silence, I have to bring this up because it's kind of crazy. And Jason, you'll remember this, Sean, this is news to you.
我要从这次节目中带走的，你的表演。但你刚才说的是，肖恩，是：“And they called them baby driver”（他们管他们叫宝贝司机）。他们管她或他或别的什么叫。他们叫我宝贝司机。但你记住的是“And they called them baby driver”。所以，这其实是一句同样有趣的歌词。是的。肖恩，你昨天说你很喜欢——你很喜欢他的那首歌《Sound of Quiet》（寂静之声）。The Sound of Quiet（安静之声）。不过顺便说一句，大家应该都知道，既然说到了《寂静之声》，我必须把这个提出来，因为这有点疯狂。杰森，你会记得的，肖恩，这对外面的你来说可能是新闻。
Jason and I worked on a project a few over the course of many years. And we had a moment when we were in the fourth incarnation of this project we were working on. We're in the middle of a strike pause where we're not naming anything. And in this project, the camera at various times would push in on me.
杰森和我多年来曾合作过一个项目。我们有过这样一个时刻，当时我们正在进行我们正在开发的这个项目的第四个版本。我们正处于罢工暂停期，我们什么名字也不能透露。在这个项目中，镜头在不同的时间会推向我。
My character, as I was having these sort of existential moments and of sort of fear and doubt and confusion, whatever. Interestation. Interestation, they play sound of silence. And it would push in, and they licensed the song for this program. And they push in on my faith. And it happened about six or seven times during... and they push it on my face. Na na na na na. Hello, Dr. Smile, friend.
我的角色，当我正经历这些存在主义的时刻——充满恐惧、怀疑和困惑，诸如此类。冥想感。冥想感，他们播放了《寂静之声》。镜头就会推过来，他们为这个节目购买了这首歌的版权。镜头推向我的脸。它在大约六七次——镜头推向我的脸。啦啦啦啦啦。你好，微笑医生，朋友。
And it happened about six or seven times during... Dr. Svetsv. Sounds very expensive. I know it was very expensive. My favorite being this one, ended up becoming a meme that they did with Ben Affleck for a long time, starting like 2016. But there's a great one, at one point,
它在大约六七次——斯韦茨夫医生。听起来很贵。我知道非常贵。我最喜欢的是这一次，它最终变成了一个迷因，人们从 2016 年开始用本·阿弗莱克（Ben Affleck）做这个。但还有一个很棒的片段，在某个时刻，
all of a sudden you hear the music start up and I say, my character says something, it pushes it on my face, and you hear, and you see a mariachi band go behind me with their truffing, and they go, oh, it's not us, and then the camera stops pushing in. Anyway, just to say that that song had a huge impact, it has had a huge impact on my life.
突然你听到音乐响起，我说——我的角色说了一些话，镜头推向我的脸，你听到音乐，然后你看到一支墨西哥马里亚奇乐队（mariachi band）从我身后走过，弹着他们的拨弦乐器，他们说：“哦，不是我们”，然后镜头停止推进。总之，就是想说那首歌产生了巨大的影响，它对我的生活产生了巨大的影响。
Hey, Paul, on the licensing thing, does every single request for licensing for stuff from music, television, commercials, anything, does it get directly to you, or does that go to your manager, does it go to your label? I mean, or do you have hands on, on who gets it and who doesn't? Well, it doesn't anymore
嘿，保罗，关于版权授权这事，每一个关于音乐、电视、广告等内容的授权请求，都是直接交给你本人，还是会经过你的经纪人，或是你的唱片公司？我的意思是，对于谁能获得授权、谁不能，你是亲力亲为的吗？嗯，现在不了，
because I sold my publishing company. Aha. About. Good for you. Two years ago, well, it was a mix, partly good and partly not good. But before that, when it was up to me, kind of, it sort of went to management. They would filter out some requests that's totally inappropriate. You can pick any kind of inappropriate combination you want.
因为我把我的版权公司卖掉了。啊哈。真为你高兴。大约——两年前，嗯，这挺复杂的，有一部分是好事，一部分不算太好。但在那之前，当这由我决定时，某种程度上，它会先到经纪管理团队那里。他们会过滤掉一些完全不合适的请求。你可以随意挑选任何不合适的组合。
But otherwise, yeah, there was some sort of a clamp for your nose for getting rid of snoring. They probably wouldn't get you. Right. For sound of silence. I would say, yeah, that's right. Well, I would say just out of curiosity, how much are they? Of course, always. Not going to say, yeah, but just out of curiosity, how much for the nose clamp on some silence?
但除此之外，是的，比如说为了治疗打鼾而夹住鼻子的夹子。他们可能不会让你用。对，用《寂静之声》。我会说，是的，没错。好吧，出于好奇，我想问问他们给多少钱？当然，总是这样。我不打算说，是的，但只是出于好奇，为了在《寂静之声》里用鼻夹，给多少钱？
To the extent you're comfortable, can you elaborate on what the good and what the bad was of selling a catalog at the risk of getting into the weeds? Yeah, sure. The good part about it is, none of my children are interested in running that company or managing that company, you know, so and I wouldn't want them to, I can understand, it's not, it's not of interest to them. So, there's no use to leave it to them because they don't want it anyway and then they'll
在你感到舒适的范围内，冒着深入细节的风险，你能详细谈谈出售版权目录的好处和坏处是什么吗？可以，当然。好处是，我的孩子们对经营那家公司或管理那家公司都没有兴趣，你知道的，所以——而且我也不希望他们这么做，我能理解，这不——这不是他们感兴趣的。所以，留给他们也没用，因为他们根本不想要，然后他们
just, so that means they'll go and sell it. So I'm better off selling it now and giving them the money rather than holding on to it. That's the good part of it. The bad part is you actually sort of lose contact with a thing that's part of you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's weird. It's a little bit, put it this way. It's good financially
还是会去把它卖掉。所以我不如现在就把它卖掉，把钱给他们，总好过死守着它。这是好的一面。坏的一面是，你实际上有点失去了与一个属于你一部分的东西的联系。是的，是的，是的。这很诡异。有点像——这么说吧。从财务角度来看是好事，
and psychologically, it's a tiny bit of a wound, you know. Yeah, it's like a divorce, probably. No. Okay. And we will be right back. Thanks to Helix for supporting SmartLess. I have sleep issues. I wake up in the middle of the night, my head starts rolling with a bunch of thoughts,
但从心理角度来看，这有点像是一道伤口，你知道的。是的，大概就像离婚一样。不。好吧。我们马上回来。感谢 Helix 对 SmartLess 的支持。我有睡眠问题。我会在半夜醒来，脑子里开始涌现各种各样的想法，
but you know what helped? My Helix dusk lux mattress. It really does. It made me sleep like a baby. The thought, like I got up in the middle of the night to go to the bathroom. I went right back to sleep and I just melt right into it. It's really, really does. It made me sleep like a baby, the thought, like I got up in the middle of the night to go to the bathroom. I went right back to sleep and I just melt right into it. It's really, really great.
但你知道什么有帮助吗？我的 Helix Dusk Luxe 床垫。它真的很管用。它真的让我睡得像个婴儿一样。那种感觉——就像我半夜起来去洗手间，然后倒头又睡着了，整个人直接陷了进去。它真的、真的很好。它真的让我睡得像个婴儿一样，那种感觉——就像我半夜起来去洗手间，然后倒头又睡着了，整个人直接陷了进去。它真的、真的太棒了。
The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Luxe collection. The newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. All right, so the Helix Elite Collection. It includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions
Helix 产品线提供 20 款独特的床垫，包括备受赞誉的 Luxe 系列。新发布的 Helix Elite 系列是一款专为体型高大睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童打造的床垫。好了，关于 Helix Elite 系列。它包含六种不同的床垫型号，每一种都针对特定的睡眠姿势
and firmness preferences. Nervous about buying a mattress online, don't be. The Helix Sleep Quiz takes into account your individual sleep preferences to match you and your partner with the perfect mattress for you. And your personalized mattress is shipped straight to your door, free of charge. Don't want to take my word.
和软硬偏好进行了量身定制。还在担心在线购买床垫吗？大可不必。Helix 睡眠测试（Helix Sleep Quiz）会考虑到你的个人睡眠偏好，为你和伴侣匹配最完美的床垫。而且你个性化定制的床垫会直接免费送货上门。不想听我一面之词？
Helix Sleep has over 12,000 five star reviews. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixleep.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long with Helix better sleep starts now. By supporting Helix, you're allowing them to support the show.
Helix Sleep 拥有超过 12,000 条五星好评。Helix 目前为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单 8 折优惠以及两个免费枕头。访问 helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，且行且珍惜，有了 Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。通过支持 Helix，也就是在支持他们支持我们的节目。
Go purchase your Helix and thank us later for your best night sleep. support the show. Go purchase your helix and thank us later for your best night's leap. Smartlist is supported by Soilent. It's a really funny name, but guess what? It's also really serious about nutrition guys calm down. We could come up with lots of jokes on the name, but the internet it's kind of already done that. So we'll just focus on how incredible the product is and the science behind it. Soilin was perfected by food scientists and tested by doctors and researchers
快去购买你的 Helix 床垫吧，你会为自己拥有史上最棒的睡眠而感谢我们的。支持我们的节目。快去购买你的 Helix 床垫吧，你会为自己拥有史上最棒的睡眠而感谢我们的。Smartlist 得到了 Soylent 的支持。这是一个非常有趣的名字，但你猜怎么着？它对营养也是极其认真的，伙计们，冷静点。我们可以针对这个名字开很多玩笑，但互联网其实已经这么干过了。所以我们还是专注于产品本身的不可思议之处以及它背后的科学吧。Soylent 经过食品科学家的完美调配，并在过去 10 年中
over the last 10 years. One bottle has all the balanced nutrients of a complete meal, vitamins, minerals, protein, healthy fat, and only one gram of sugar, and it actually tastes great. In fact, at one product of the year, this science-backed food hack is the perfect meal for when you don't want to think about food. Soilin is convenient and requires no refrigeration,
接受了医生和研究人员的测试。一瓶就含有完整一餐的所有均衡营养：维生素、矿物质、蛋白质、健康脂肪，而且只有一克糖，它实际上味道非常好。事实上，它曾荣获年度产品奖，这种有科学依据的食物替代方案，是你不想考虑吃什么时的完美代餐。Soylent 使用方便，无需冷藏，
so you can have breakfast or lunch, whenever or wherever you need or want. And believe me, I'm always on the go. And what I did this week, I grabbed, as I was going out the door, I grabbed a Soilin Vanilla high protein shake. It's so good. I love anything vanilla or chocolate.
所以你可以随时随地享用早餐或午餐，无论何时何地你需要或想要。相信我，我总是行色匆匆。我这周做的是，出门时顺手抓了一瓶
But mostly vanilla. And I like shakes in vanilla, because let's face it, it's mother's milk all over again. or chocolate. But mostly vanilla, and I like shakes in vanilla, because let's face it, it's mother's milk all over again. Go to Amazon now and get soy lent for 30% off using smartness. I repeat, go to Amazon now and get soy lent for 30% off using smartness. This episode is brought to you in part by Topgolf.
Soylent 香草味高蛋白奶昔。太好喝了。我喜欢任何香草或巧克力味的东西。但主要是香草味。而且我喜欢香草味的奶昔，因为说实话，这感觉就像是重新喝到了母乳。或者巧克力味。但主要是香草味，而且我喜欢香草味的奶昔，因为说实话，这感觉就像是重新喝到了母乳。现在去亚马逊使用 smartless 购买 Soylent 可享 7 折优惠。我再说一遍，现在去亚马逊使用 smartless 购买 Soylent 可享 7 折优惠。本集部分内容由 Topgolf 赞助播出。
It's golf. It's not golf. It's Topgolf, right? If anybody knows golf, it's not me. But Topgolf is amazing. You'll get clubs, balls, teas, turf, a ball, picker, upper-cart thing, but you'll also get loud. Music, giant targets in their giant fairway, giant TVs, and a handcrafted food and beverage menu,
这是高尔夫。又不是高尔夫。这是 Topgolf，对吧？如果说有人懂高尔夫，那绝对不是我。但 Topgolf 太棒了。你会得到球杆、球、球座（tees）、人造草皮、捡球车之类的东西，但你也会感受到热闹的氛围。
put all these things under one roof, and you get yourself a good time, guys. So consider this your formal invitation to grab the fam, a few friends or some co-workers, and come play around. Don't golf like me, doesn't matter. Golf can be kind of hard, right? But no one is not good at top golf.
音乐、他们巨大球道上的巨型靶标、巨型电视，以及手工制作的食品和饮料菜单，把所有这些东西汇聚在一个屋檐下，伙计们，你们就会玩得很开心。所以，把这当作你的正式邀请，带上家人、几个朋友或一些同事，来打上一场吧。别像我一样不会打高尔夫，没关系。高尔夫可能有点难，对吧？但没有人会在 Topgolf 里玩不转。
Everyone can play top golf. Even if you've never swung a club before, I go, and I have a blast, and do a little putt putt thing. I hit the ball around, I grab some food, I sit down, I turn on the big giant TV and I watch my favorite reality programs. I'm in, it's so much fun. And you're around all this fun constantly.
每个人都能玩 Topgolf。即使你从来没挥过杆，我去的时候也玩得超开心，还会玩玩迷你高尔夫（putt putt）。我把球击出去，吃点东西，坐下来，打开超大电视，观看我最喜欢的真人秀节目。我太喜欢了，真的非常有趣。而且你一直身处这种欢乐的氛围中。
It's like a high energy kick, you'll love it. Visit topgolf.com slash smartless to book a bay and come play around. That's topgolf.com slash smartless to book a bay and come play around. That's topgolf.com slash smartless. All right, back to the show. You know, Paul, I remember that one sketch you did on this one sketch show. It's very, it's very famous now. And it has to do with what we're doing to you, which is everybody. You're standing in line to get into like a movie or something. Oh, yeah, it's a very standing in line to get into like a movie or something. And we have some very famous,
这就像是一剂高能量的强心针，你会爱上它的。访问 topgolf.com/smartless 预订球位，来打上一场吧。网址是 topgolf.com/smartless 预订球位，来打上一场吧。网址是 topgolf.com/smartless。好了，回到节目中。你知道，保罗，我还记得你在那个小品节目里演过的那个小品。现在非常有名。这和我们对你做的事情有关，也就是所有人。你排队等着进电影院什么的。哦，对，就是排队等着进电影院什么的。我们有一些非常有名的人，
and they say something like, I'm gonna get this wrong. But like, you know, hey, Paul, I played in your band of the lot, do you remember me? No. Hey, Paul, I was like, you know, I was a friend of yours back in high school. Do you remember me? No.
他们会说一些类似于——我可能会说错。但就像是，“嘿，保罗，我以前在你的乐队里弹过琴，你记得我吗？”“不。”“嘿，保罗，我——你知道，我曾是你高中的朋友。你记得我吗？”“不。”
And then somebody, it builds up to the last person going, Paul, I was sitting on a little red rug in the middle of Central Park, like about 10,000 feet from you during your live concert. And you're like, Jim, how are you? It's so great. That was funny. And it was such a, it's such a, uh, uh, that was funny. Speaking of Central Park, is there any chance that you'll ever play Central Park again? No. Yeah. There's no chance that I'll, I don't think there's much chance that I'll play again.
然后有人——最后一个人说：“保罗，在你的现场演唱会上，我曾坐在中央公园正中央的一张小红毯上，离你大约一万英尺远。”而你却说：“吉姆，你好吗？真是太棒了。”这太搞笑了。这是一个——这是一个——那太搞笑了。说到中央公园，你还有没有可能再次在中央公园演出？不会了。是的。我再去演的机率不大了，我觉得没有什么机率了。
No. Because, well, I don't, uh, well, I'll just say, get it over with. I lost the hearing in my left ear about a year ago. It's just about one year now. Oh, I'm sorry. And I can't, I can't hear when drums and electric guitar playing. I can't sing with it. I can't hear my voice in the mix. So I can't perform with a band. I might be able to perform this piece that I did, Seven Psalms, which is just acoustic guitar. I'm going to try that next month with two guitar, displaying
因为，嗯，我不想——好吧，我直说吧，长话短说。大约一年前，我失去了左耳的听力。现在差不多刚好一年了。哦，我很抱歉。当有鼓和电吉他演奏时，我听不见。我无法随着它唱歌。我在混音中听不到自己的声音。所以我无法和乐队一起演出。我或许能表演我创作的这部作品《Seven Psalms》（七首赞美诗），那只有木吉他。我打算下个月尝试一下，由两把吉他演奏
the parts that I wrote. And see if I, because I think I can handle that much sound, but more than that, not, it's blown me out. It's it's it's a drag. Yeah, I mean, I'm sorry. No, that is a drag in it. But anyway, you can't play Central Park. They don't want anybody to play in Central Park. And I think I'm the reason too.
我写的部分。看看我能不能——因为我认为我能应付那种程度的声音，但再多就不行了，这对我打击很大。这真的很扫兴。是的，我的意思是，我很抱歉。不，这确实很扫兴。不过话说回来，你不能在中央公园演出。他们不希望任何人再去中央公园演出。而且我认为原因也有我。
The concert that I did there in 1991 had by the police estimate 750,000 people. I think there was just so much damage done to Central Park from the just people walking over the great lawn that they they've restricted concerts there and they and when they do have them, they restrict the size. So there won't be any of those events like the Simon and Garfold talk. And also it took up a lot of valuable space
根据警方的估计，我在 1991 年在那里举办的那场演唱会吸引了 75 万人。我想仅仅是因为人们在大草坪上走来走去，对中央公园造成了太大的破坏，所以他们限制了那里的演唱会，而且即使举办，他们也会限制规模。所以不会再有像西蒙和加芬克尔（Simon and Garfunkel）那种规模的活动了。而且它也占用了大量宝贵的空间
from drug dealers and Pimps and stuff. They got had to move to different areas. Let me just, Paul, I wanted to talk to you. You mentioned seven Psalms, which I just think is pretty remarkable. I just listened to it. And it's hard to, I was like, you guys haven't heard it yet. I don't think, but it's sort of part song and part album.
用来给毒贩和皮条客之类的人活动。他们不得不搬到别的区域。保罗，我只是想跟你聊聊。你提到了《七首赞美诗》，我觉得这非常了不起。我刚刚听了。而且很难——我当时想：你们大概还没听过，但我认为这有点像歌曲和专辑的结合体。
It's kind of one, and forgive me, Paul, if I'm not doing a good job of describing it. It's like a one long piece it seems like, and it starts with these, what I think are bells and then kind of ends with the bells as well. Am I right in that Paul? Almost. The, and is the long piece is a 33 minute piece and it's meant to be played in its entirety. But the, the sounds that you heard as bells, they do, they do sound something like bells. They're actually an instrument called a cloud bowl. That
它有点像是一个整体，保罗，如果我没有把它的特点描述好，请原谅我。它似乎是一首很长的作品，一开始是这些——我认为是钟声的声音，然后到最后也伴随着钟声结束。保罗，我没说错吧？差不多。那首长作品是一首 33 分钟的作品，它本来就是要作为一个整体来播放的。但是，你听到的那些听起来像钟声的声音，它们确实听起来有点像钟声。它们其实是一种叫做“云碗”（cloud-bowl）的乐器，
was invented by a composer named Harry Parch. And Harry Parch is kind of a very interesting cul de sac composer. He said the division of an octave into 12 notes, you know, if you look at a piano, and you start with C, and you play to C, and you include the white and black keys, you have 12 tones in an octave. He said, that's a European conception that an octave is divided into 12 tones. It's arbitrary. Actually, he thought it was divided into 42 microtones. So in order to play the music that he heard, which was divided into these 42 notes in an octave, he had to invent instruments that could play in that small of an interval. to invent instruments that could play in that small of an interval. And one of the instruments that he invented
是由一位名叫哈里·帕奇（Harry Parch）的作曲家发明的。哈里·帕奇有点像是一个非常有趣的死胡同式作曲家。他说，把一个八度音阶划分为 12 个音符——你知道的，如果你看一架钢琴，从 C 开始，弹到 C，把白键和黑键都算上，一个八度里有 12 个音调。他说，八度音阶被划分为 12 个音调，这是欧洲人的概念。这是随心所欲定下来的。实际上，他认为它应该被划分为 42 个微音阶。因此，为了演奏他所听到的那种被划分为一个八度里 42 个音符的音乐，他不得不发明能够以如此微小音程演奏的乐器。为了演奏能够达到如此微小音程的乐器，他发明了
was this cloud bowl, which was a picture, picture of wine glass that's maybe three feet in diameter and another three or four feet high, hung upside down and you hit it with a mallet and it produces that tone. That's a, you'll cut all of this out because it's... No, no, are you kidding? It's only interesting.
其中的一种乐器就是这个云碗，它是一个大酒杯的形状，直径可能有三英尺，高度大概还有三到四英尺，倒挂着，你用木槌敲击它，它就会发出那种音调。这是一个——你们会把这些都剪掉的，因为这……不，不，你在开玩笑吗？这太有趣了。
No, I think it's interesting. It's interesting to me as this. Yes. But it does start with those... No, I was just saying, if you're using all of those tones that are in the middle of the chromatic scale, then how would that blend in with any chord? It would just sound so dissonant. It does.
不，我觉得这很有趣。对我来说这很有趣。但是它确实是以那些……不，我只是在想，如果你使用的是半音阶中间的所有那些音调，那么它怎么能和任何和弦融合呢？听起来会非常刺耳。确实如此。
If you blend it with tonal music, it's going to sound dissonant, but it doesn't necessarily have to sound dissonant in a way that is not pleasing. For example, if you're playing whatever your keyboard or your composing or you're making something and in the distance you hear a church bell ringing and maybe in another further distance you hear a second church bell, the sound of those two bells, they don't make what you're playing sound less interesting. They probably enhance it. There's something about that, those overtones that we really like, and I think that's maybe what was parts was on to, but in this piece, Seven Psalms, I use a lot of different bells and percussion instruments that are not really
如果你把它和调性音乐融合在一起，听起来会很刺耳，但它不一定非得以一种令人不悦的方式听起来刺耳。例如，无论你是在弹奏你的键盘、还是在作曲、或者在创作什么东西，在远处你听到教堂的钟声在响，也许在更远的地方你听到第二声教堂钟声，那两个钟声的声音并不会让你正在弹奏的东西听起来不那么有趣。它们可能会增色不少。那些泛音有某种我们非常喜欢的特质，我想这也许就是帕奇所追求的，但在《七首赞美诗》这首作品中，我用了许多不同的钟声和打击乐器，它们其实并不在
in the key, but they enhance the acoustic guitar. Yeah. Have you ever heard of the German term Klangfarben music? No, I haven't. What's that mean? It's kind of what we're talking about. It's an overall term that means, you know, it's more color in a song rather than within a chord.
调性之内，但它们衬托了木吉他。是的。你听说过德语术语 Klangfarben（音色音乐）吗？没有，我没听说过。那是什么意思？这正是我们正在谈论的。这是一个总称，意思是，你知道的，它更多的是在一首歌中展现色彩，而不是局限于某个和弦之内。
It's just for atmospheric kind of feeling. Well, that term applies to seven songs. There is a lot of that to create a certain atmosphere. And in the same way that I said, Oh, the listener completes the song, I believe that when the listener listens to things, if you give them a certain sound, and you place it just far enough so that they can just hear it, there's a creative depth in your hearing. And that depth, just like if you imagine the church bells in the distance, there's something about that that opens the listener or maybe I'm just speaking for myself
它只是为了营造一种氛围感。嗯，这个术语完全适用于《七首赞美诗》。这里面有很多这样的元素来营造某种特定的氛围。就像我刚才说的，“听众完成了这首歌”，我相信当听众在听这些东西时，如果你给他们一种特定的声音，把它放在恰到好处的远处，让他们刚好能听到，你的听觉中就有一种创作的深度。而这种深度——就像你想象远处的教堂钟声一样，这种声音有一种魔力，能让听众在情感上敞开心扉，或者也许我只是在代表我个人
personally, but I think I'm not, I think it's true for a lot of people. There's something about these distant sounds that open us up emotionally. And if as a writer, a songwriter, if I can produce sounds that allow the listener to open themselves emotionally, then whatever it is that I have to say lyrically has a chance of being really meaningful. Of landing. Yeah. And of really right. You sort of like you've laid the groundwork for them to really absorb the lyrics. It's interesting to hear you talk about it in this way. I'm fascinated in listening to Seven Psalms. it is a really remarkable piece. And I feel like albums are often meant to be heard in their entirety, at least they used to be.
说话，但我认为我并非特例，我觉得这对很多人来说都是真的。这种来自远方的声音有某种东西能在情感上打开我们的心扉。如果作为一个作家、词曲作者，我能创作出能让听众在情感上敞开心扉的声音，那么无论我在歌词中想表达什么，都有机会变得真正意义深远。能够真正触动人心。是的。而且真正正确。这就好像你为他们真正吸收歌词打下了基础。听你这样谈论它真的很有意思。我听《七首赞美诗》时深深着迷，这确实是一部非凡的作品。我觉得专辑往往就是为了让人完整聆听而创作的，至少过去是这样的。
And this kind of, in a lot of ways, forces you to listen to it as one piece because it is kind of one continuous piece that's made up of all these different peaks and valleys. And it occurs to me listening to you talk about it and talking about people and really how important actually the listener is to you. I really believe in that more than ever. Has that changed or evolved at all when you started first making records
在很多方面，这种创作会迫使你把它当作一个整体来聆听，因为它本身就是一段由各种高潮和低谷组成的连续不断的音乐。听你谈论它，谈论人们，以及听众对你而言究竟有多重要，这让我意识到……我比以往任何时候都更加坚信这一点。从你刚开始制作唱片
or recording? I mean, before you were recording with, I guess you had been recording with art, but when you recorded a lot of stuff and had some hits on your own under different suit and tips like Jerry Landis, I think it was one of the names you used and you had a bunch of different names. Oh, when I was a teenager, you up at none of that were hits. No, but you had, but you had a few charts, but did you, did you, did you always have that approach to this approach of music and just got more refined
或者录音的时候起，这种心态有没有过什么改变或演变？我是说，在你开始录音之前——我想你之前跟Art合作录过音，但当你录制了大量作品并在不同化名下拥有了一些自己的热门单曲时，比如Jerry Landis，我想这是你曾用过的名字之一，你当时用过很多不同的名字。哦，那是我十几岁的时候，那些可全都没有火。不，不过你确实有几首曲子上过排行榜，但你、但你、你对音乐一直都是这种态度吗，还是说这种态度后来变得更加精炼了？
or when was it that you started to really understand or I don't know. Yeah, I understand this right. When were you cognizant of? I think what I had naturally, I think was this understanding, but I didn't intellectually think of it. So when I was 23 years old and I wrote the sound of silence, I didn't think anything other than that's probably my best song up till now.
或者说，是从什么时候开始你才真正开始理解——或者我不知道。对，我这么理解对吗。你是从什么时候开始意识到这一点的？我想我骨子里对这一点是有这种认知的，但我并没有从理智上去思考过它。所以在23岁那年，当我写出《The Sound of Silence》时，我脑子里唯一的想法就是，这可能是我到目前为止写得最好的一首歌。
I didn't think about anything. It's only later, and maybe in the last 15 years or something like that, that I begin to think, why do we like this sound? What is it about this song that makes me love it and remember it from all the other songs that were happening at the same time when I was, you know, of that age when it, when I was really receptive to music. And if I were to, to throw the question back to you on a comedic level, if you're setting up a comedic environment where what you can do is going to
我什么都没想。直到后来，也许也就是在过去15年左右的时间里，我才开始思考：为什么我们喜欢这种声音？这首歌究竟有什么魔力，让我对它爱不释手，并在我处于那个年龄、真正容易被音乐打动的时候，从当时同时出现的那么多歌曲中唯独记住它？如果把这个问题抛给你，从喜剧的角度来看，如果你正在营造一种喜剧氛围，让你能够
achieve what you want, which is to get people to laugh and also to think, that's true. I'm, it's, I'm laughing, but it laughing, but I also know that's really true. It's part of my enjoyment is that, well, in order to do that, I mean, you can do it when you're young, you do it naturally. And later on, you think, why is that funny?
达到你想要的效果——也就是既能逗笑大家，又能引发思考：“说得太对了，我虽然在笑，但我知道这确实是事实。”这种认同感也是我享受的一部分。嗯，为了做到这一点，我的意思是，当你年轻的时候，你可以很自然地做到这一点。而到了后来，你就会去想：为什么这很好笑？
What do I need to do that? And a lot of it need to do that? And a lot of it has to do with attention span of the listener or the viewer. So I think a lot about attention span, because my attention span, well, it is what it is. So at a certain point, when I'm writing, I think, I'm tired of this. It's time for me to change a pattern. Maybe you're a change of rhythmic pattern. Maybe change the key that I'm in. Maybe change whatever.
我需要做什么才能达到这个效果？很大一部分原因在于听众或观众的注意力持续时间。所以我经常思考注意力持续时间这个问题，因为我的注意力持续时间嘛，反正就是那样。所以在创作的某个阶段，当我写到一定程度时，我会想：我厌倦这个了，是时候改变一下模式了。也许改变一下节奏模式，也许改变一下调性，也许改变其他什么。
My attention span is saying that I'm bored and I'm about to bail out. That's what I think the listener does all the time. You listen to most music or most comedy. And if you're not drawn into it, if you're not hooked, you're leaving. You're mentally leaving, you know. And with a comic, if they're not funny for a long enough period of time, and that might be a minute and a half, maybe it's five minutes, whatever. You're not, that set is blown. You're not going to, you're gone.
我的注意力在告诉我，我已经觉得无聊了，快要坚持不下去了。我想听众在听的时候也是这种状态。你听大部分音乐或大部分喜剧时，如果你被吸引进去了，如果你被迷住了，你就留下来了；如果你没有，你的精神就已经开小差了，你知道的。而对于喜剧演员来说，如果他们够不上好笑的状态持续了足够长的时间——可能是一分半钟，也可能是五分钟，随便多久——那这场演出就砸了，你留不住观众了，他们已经走了。
Same with the song. They component to comedy is, is, is surprise and, and lack of predictability. And, and, and you, you, you do that. I would, I would think without even trying. There's, there's nothing predictable, there's nothing boring about your music. In fact, you were constantly changing your sound and things just become even more sort of sophisticated
歌曲也是一样。喜剧的一个重要成分是——是——是惊喜，以及不可预测性。而且——而且——你做到了这一点。我想，你甚至都不用刻意去尝试就能做到。你的音乐没有任何可预测性，也没有任何无聊的地方。事实上，你一直在不断改变你的声音，各种元素甚至变得更加复杂、
and layered, and I'm not sure what the right words would be, but it never seemed common. I mean, in all the decades you've been making music, and in fact, there was something very, very human and vulnerable and connecting to the real deep and small part inside of me, always, and can you attribute that sense of... By the way, JB, to what you're saying, and maybe you can put this in, think about all the different types of music, the way, JB, to kind of to what you're saying. And maybe you can put this in,
更有层次感，我不知道该用什么词来形容，但它听起来从来都不是平庸的。我是说，在你创作音乐的几十年里，事实上，里面总有一种非常非常人性化、脆弱且能触及我内心深处最私密、最柔软角落的东西，一直都是这样。你能把这种感觉归因于……顺便说一句，杰森（JB），顺应着你刚才的话，也许你可以把这个加进去，想想所有不同类型的音乐，那种方式……杰森，顺着你刚才的意思。也许你可以把这个加进去，
think about all the different types of music of the world music that Paul got into and all that stuff. I mean, and all that still spoke to us, even though it was different. My response to that is it's not different. They put a name on it and call it world music, but I thought I don't see why any of this is different from any other piece of popular music that I like. And I thought that way going back into the bridge over trouble water album, which has a song called El Condor Pasa, which is like a 400-year-old Peruvian, maybe that's maybe it's two, three hundred-year-old, it's an old Peruvian melody, and it's lasted that long. I heard it performed in Paris in 1965 by this folk group,
想想保罗接触过的世界各地各种不同类型的音乐，诸如此类的种种。我是说，所有这些音乐仍然能与我们产生共鸣，尽管它们风格迥异。对此我的回应是：它们本质上并没有什么不同。人们给它贴上标签，叫它“世界音乐”，但我当时觉得，我不明白这跟我喜欢的任何其他流行音乐有什么不同。从创作《Bridge Over Troubled Water》这张专辑时起，我就一直是这么想的，里面有一首歌叫《El Condor Pasa》，它就像是一首有400年历史的秘鲁——也许是两、三百年历史吧——一首古老的秘鲁旋律，它流传了那么久。我在1965年在巴黎听过这个民谣乐队的表演，
and I loved it, and I thought, oh, I really love that. Why can't I write a lyric to that? I'll just get the permission from the people who recorded it. And I'll put a lyric onto it. The same was just true with a mother and child reunion. It's not like I said, oh, I'll do this because it's reggae. No, I just like that sound. It didn't sound incompatible with other music sounds that I liked.
我非常喜欢，当时我就想：哦，我真的很喜欢这个。为什么我不能为它填词呢？我只要去征得录音者的许可就行了。然后我就可以为它填上歌词。创作《Mother and Child Reunion》时也是如此。并不是说我说：“哦，我要做这个，因为它是雷鬼音乐。”不，我只是喜欢那种声音。它听起来与其他我喜欢的音乐并没有什么冲突。
And if you go, I guess I'm in a way, by my age, I'm privileged in that the music that I listen to, that I fell in love with, which is in the 50s, is really world music. I mean, you have, as I said, the Everly Brothers, well, that sound is appallation music. I mean, you have, as I said, the Everly Brothers, well, that sound is Appalachian music, you know, those harmonies and those harmonies are Celtic that come from Ireland, they come from England, that's that sound. Do up comes from gospel quartets, those gospel quartets from the black church. That's another culture. Elvis Presley
如果你去了解的话——我想从某种程度上来说，凭借我的年龄，我是幸运的，因为我聆听并爱上的音乐（也就是50年代的音乐）其实就是真正的世界音乐。我的意思是，正如我所说，Everly Brothers（埃弗利兄弟），那种声音就是阿巴拉契亚音乐。我是说，正如我所说，Everly Brothers，那种声音就是阿巴拉契亚音乐，你知道的，那些和声，那些和声其实是源自爱尔兰、源自英国的凯尔特音乐，那就是那种声音。Doo-wop（嘟咕嘟）则源自黑人教堂的福音四重唱。那是另一种文化。埃尔维斯·普雷斯利（Elvis Presley）
is combining country with rhythm and blues. Music from Louisiana is being is syncopated because it's drawing from rhythms from that come up from the African diaspora of the drum. It's coming up through the Caribbean, finds its way into Louisiana. That mixes with French accordion and fiddle music and becomes zytaco. All of these were put together. They were all hits in the 50s and they just called it rock and roll. And I was 13 years old and I just thought it's all the same music. What do you attribute your, I mean your taste is not common, you know, like you never seem to write a common song or put up with something that is easy and commercial and what do you attribute your taste, your confidence, your sophistication in music? Like, did your parents encourage you to like stuff that's a little bit more challenging? Or is it just the bands, as you said, that you ended up falling in love with as a kid?
将乡村音乐与节奏布鲁斯融合在了一起。来自路易斯安那州的音乐带有切分音，因为它汲取了源自非洲鼓乐文化散落各地的节奏。这些节奏通过加勒比海传入路易斯安那，然后与法国手风琴和小提琴音乐融合，就成了柴迪科音乐（Zydeco）。所有这些元素都被组合在了一起。它们在50年代全都是热门歌曲，人们当时统称它们为摇滚乐。我当时13岁，就觉得这其实都是同一类音乐。你把你的……我是说，你的品位并不平庸，你知道的，你似乎从来不会写一首平庸的歌，也从不妥协于那些流于表面、迎合商业的烂大街东西，你把你的品位、自信以及在音乐上的成熟度归功于什么？比如，你的父母是否曾鼓励你去听一些更有挑战性的东西？还是就像你说的，仅仅是因为那些你小时候最终爱上的乐队，
And then that just identified and built your taste. Well, my father was a musician, and I would say he didn't like the music that I liked. There was a huge division between his generation and mine. He loved music from a big band era and that's what he probably grew up playing. He wasn't interested at all in rock and roll. So no, he didn't encourage me or give me any of that. Well, I guess he did, but I wasn't interested. You know, like he loved classical music.
然后这些音乐塑造并确立了你的品位？嗯，我父亲是个音乐家，不过平心而论，他并不喜欢我喜欢的音乐。他的那一代人和我的这一代人之间存在着巨大的代沟。他深爱大乐队时代的音乐，那可能也是他年轻时靠演奏起家的音乐。他对摇滚乐完全不感兴趣。所以，不，他并没有鼓励我，也没有给我灌输过这些。好吧，我想他其实给过我一些影响，但我当时不感兴趣。你知道的，比如他酷爱古典音乐。
He loved mallar, you know? And our member him playing is for me, not when I was a kid, but you know, when when I was already in my 40s or maybe your early 50s, he said, this is what I love, this mallard's fifth. So I listened to it and I thought it's inexplicable while why people love what they love, but I don't love it. But he does. And so anyway, no, they didn't
他酷爱马勒，你知道吗？我记得他专门为我播放过马勒的作品，不是在我小时候，而是在我已经40多岁、甚至快50岁的时候，他说：“这是我最挚爱的东西，马勒的第五交响曲。”所以我听了，然后心想：人们为什么会爱他们所爱，这真是让人匪夷所思，但我就是不爱。不过他爱。所以总之，这跟他们
have anything to do with it. But you said something that was interesting, Jason. Oh, boy. We probably marked it because we're going to circle the day. I was just basically asking, you know, what can you attribute your, your non-common taste to and your confidence in always putting out something that never sounds the same as the last? Okay, so why let's go to the confidence thing first, okay, because I don't have confidence. I don't. I don't buy it. I think I quite often think this is no good. You know, but then then I say to myself, it's just it's just a distraction to think this is no good. It's not improving anything. Just go ahead and do what you what you feel, you know, and by the way,
没有任何关系。不过你刚才说了一件很有趣的事，杰森。噢，天哪。我们大概得把这段标出来，因为我们要好好回味一下这一天。我刚才其实只是在问，你知道的，你如何把你不平庸的品位，以及你总能创作出与上一首截然不同的作品的那份自信归结于什么？好吧，那我们先来谈谈“自信”这件事，好吗？因为我其实并没有自信。我真的没有。我不买账。我经常会觉得：“这写得真烂。”你知道的，但紧接着我就会对自已说：“觉得这写得烂纯粹只是一种干扰。它对改善现状没有任何帮助。只管去做你内心感受到的东西就行了。”而且顺便说一句，
it takes a battle to get rid of that voice that says, this is no good. That's so good. That's no good, you know. We all have it. We all have that, right? So I don't really have confidence. What I feel is, it's like people used to say at a certain period of time when I was writing hits all the time, oh, you have your finger on the pulse. And I would think my finger is out there and the pulse is running under it at the moment. But it's going to, the pulse is going to leave. But I'm still going to have, I'm still going to be exploring with my finger to see where I want to go.
要摆脱那个对你说“这写得太烂了、这太逊了、这根本不行”的声音，需要经历一番心理斗争。我们都有这种声音。我们每个人都有，对吧？所以我其实并没有真正的自信。我的感觉是，就像人们在某个时期——当我一直在创作热门歌曲的时候——经常说的那样：“哦，你对流行脉搏的把控真是恰到好处。”而我当时的内心想法是：“我的手指只是恰好放在那儿，脉搏刚好在它下面流淌而已。但脉搏总会流走的。不过我依然会继续，我依然会用我的手指去探索，去寻找我想去的地方。”
Sometimes I'm going to go to a place that's less well-known, like South African music, and many, many people will say, oh, I love that. And they'll agree with me. And then sometimes I'll go to a place like a combination of Latin music and duop, like what I wrote in the Cape Man, which is a Broadway, which is a musical that I wrote for Broadway, which is a gigantic flop, critically, commercially, everything. And now nobody was interested in what I was thinking. So really, what can you do other than just to go to what you're interested in? Because if you decide you're going to go and see, now I wonder what people are interested in and I'll go and do that. You'll just fail.
有时候，我会去一些不那么为人所知的地方，比如南非音乐，然后会有很多人说：“哦，我太喜欢这个了。”他们会赞同我的选择。但有时，我会去尝试一些融合了拉丁音乐和Doo-wop风格的东西，就像我在《The Capeman》里写的那样——这是一部百老汇音乐剧，是我为百老汇写的一部作品，结果它在评论界、商业上等方方面面都惨败，成了一部名副其实的惊天大烂片。当时根本没有人对我的想法感兴趣。所以说，除了坚持做你感兴趣的事之外，你还能怎么办呢？因为如果你决定去迎合大众：“现在让我看看大家对什么感兴趣，然后我就去做那个。”那你最终只会失败。
You'll never get it, right? And if you do get it right, well then if you do figure that out, well then you're not an artist anymore. It's hollow. It doesn't have any heart. And if you believe that it's essential to have heart, then you discard that as a choice. And if you don't believe in heart
你永远拿捏不对，对吧？就算你真的押中了，如果你真的把那个迎合大众的公式琢磨透了，那你也就不再是一个真正的艺术家了。那将是空洞的。它没有任何灵魂。如果你认为“灵魂”是至关重要的，那么你就会把那种市侩的选择抛弃。如果你根本不相信灵魂的重要性，
and you're just interested in success, well, then you pursue another path towards success. Yeah. We'll be right back. SmartLess Get support from Rocket Money. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Most people think they're spending $80 on their subscriptions,
而只对成功感兴趣，好吧，那你大可去追求通往成功的另一条路。好的，我们马上回来。SmartLess。感谢 Rocket Money 的赞助支持。Rocket Money 是一款个人理财应用程序，可以帮你集中查找并取消那些你不需要的订阅服务、监控支出，并帮助你削减账单。大多数人以为自己花在订阅服务上的钱大约是 80 美元，
when in reality, the number is closer to $200. When you're signed up for so many things like streaming services you used to watch one show or free trials for delivery you don't use, it's so easy to lose track of what you're paying for, but with rocket money you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service, rocket money does all the work for you. Rocket money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and rocket money takes care of the rest. Stop wasting money on things you don't use.
但现实是，这个数字往往接近 200 美元。当你订阅了那么多东西——比如只看了一场节目的流媒体服务，或是那些你根本不用、却绑定了免费试用的配送服务——你很容易就会搞不清自己到底在为哪些花销买单。但有了 Rocket Money，你只需按一下按钮，就能轻松取消那些你不想要的服务。再也不用忍受漫长的电话等待，或者给客服发那些烦人的电子邮件，Rocket Money 会为你代劳一切。Rocket Money 甚至可以帮你与商家谈判，将你的账单削减最多 20%。你所需要做的，就是拍下你的账单照片，剩下的全交给 Rocket Money 来处理。别再把钱浪费在你不用 A 的东西上了。
Council, you're unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless. Rocket money.comsmartless.com Thanks to GoodRx for their support. Feeling under the weather this cold and flu season, GoodRx is here to help with savings on prescription cold and flu meds for the whole family.
取消那些你不需要的订阅，用最简单的方式管理你的财务，快去访问 rocketmoney.com/smartless。网址是 rocketmoney.com/smartless。rocketmoney.com/smartless。感谢 GoodRx 对本节目的支持。在这个感冒和流感高发的季节里，你是否觉得身体有点不舒服？GoodRx 来帮忙了，它可以帮全家人节省处方感冒药和流感药的费用。
And if you still need a flu shot, GoodRx can help you find one at an affordable price. They also have tons of information and resources to help you stay healthy all season and beyond. With goodRx, you can instantly find discounts, compare prices, and save up to 80% of the pharmacy. All you need to do is search for your medication on the goodRx website or app and show your discount at the pharmacy. It's that easy. GoodRx has accepted all the major pharmacies in your neighborhood, including CVS, Walgreens, Rite Aid, Vans, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more. And remember, goodRx is not insurance, but it works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance, goodRx may beat your copay price. For big savings on cold and flu meds, plus discounts on your everyday
如果你还没打流感疫苗，GoodRx 也能帮你以实惠的价格找到接种点。他们还提供大量的信息和资源，帮助你在整个流感季甚至更久保持健康。通过 GoodRx，你可以即时找到药店折扣、对比价格，在药店最高节省 80% 的费用。你只需要在 GoodRx 网站或应用程序上搜索你的药物，然后在药店出示折扣信息即可。就是这么简单。GoodRx 被你家附近的各大主流药店所接受，包括 CVS、Walgreens、Rite Aid、Vons、Walmart、Sam's Club 等等。请记住，GoodRx 不是保险，但无论你是否有保险，它都能派上用场。即使你有保险，GoodRx 的价格也可能会比你的医保自付额更便宜。要想在感冒和流感药物上省下一大笔钱，外加日常
prescriptions, go to goodRx.com slash smartless. That's goodrx.com slash smartless. Smartless is supported by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. Audible offers an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre. You'll find guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities,
处方药的折扣，请访问 goodRx.com/smartless。网址是 goodrx.com/smartless。Smartless 得到了 Audible 的支持。Audible 让你在一个应用程序中享受所有有声娱乐内容。你总能找到自己挚爱的最佳内容，或是发现全新的惊喜。Audible 在各个流派中都提供了令人难以置信的有声书精选。你可以找到由顶级名人、
renowned experts, and exciting new voices in audio. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. The Audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere, while traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. So I've been checking out Atomic Habits by James Clear.
知名专家和有声书界激动人心的新锐声音带来的正念健康计划、戏剧表演、喜剧以及独家 Audible 原创作品。作为 Audible 会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中选择并永久保留一本作品，包括最新的畅销书和新发行作品。Audible 应用程序让你无论在旅行、健身、散步还是做家务时，都能随时随地轻松收听，全由你作主。我最近一直在听詹姆斯·克利尔（James Clear）的《原子习惯》（Atomic Habits）。
I love his last name. It's so apropos. It's a great, great audiobook. It'll teach you exactly how to form good habits, break bad ones, and master the tiny behaviors that lead to amazing, amazing results. I really, really highly recommend it. You know, we always joke about on the podcast how we don't read, but listening to an audiobook seems to be more time-efficient for us, and I really, really enjoy actually listening to books. It's fantastic. I'm reading again with my ears. New members can try
我太喜欢他的姓氏了。真是太贴切了。这是一本非常非常棒的有声书。它会确切地教你如何养成好习惯、戒掉坏习惯，并掌握那些能带来惊人成效的微小行为。我真的、真的极力推荐它。你知道的，我们在播客里总是开玩笑说我们不怎么读书，但听有声书对我们来说似乎更有效率，我其实非常非常享受听书的过程。这太棒了。我又开始用耳朵阅读了。新会员可以免费试用
audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Did you ever get close to pursuing acting even more than you did because you're fantastic at it. You seem very, very comfortable at it.
Audible 30 天。请访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。网址是 audible.com/smartless，或者发送短信 smartless 到 500-500，即可免费试用 Audible 30 天。audible.com/smartless。现在让我们回到节目中。你有没有曾一度考虑过更深入地去尝试表演，甚至超过你目前的程度？因为你在这方面实在太棒了。你看上去在表演时非常非常自然、松弛。
You know, I have some skillset in doing comedy. I don't think I could do any other kind of serious acting and play anything other than myself. I couldn't submerge myself. Oh, that's not surprising to me because you brought up comedy before and there is a connection there with music and comedy because they're both about rhythm, right? Yeah. At their core. And I think that there's, you guys feel the same, tell me the same thing.
你知道的，我在演喜剧方面确实有一些天赋技能。我觉得自己演不了其他任何严肃的戏剧，也演不了除我自己之外的任何角色。我无法让自己完全沉浸到另一个角色中去。哦，这对我来说并不意外，因为你刚才提到了喜剧，喜剧和音乐之间其实是有共通之处的，因为它们都关乎节奏，对吧？是的。其核心就在于此。我觉得，你们大家也有同感，告诉我你们是不是也这么觉得。
I, you know, over the years, I've met so many bands who are really, really into comedy. And I know so many comed bands who are really, really into comedy and I know so many comedians who are really into music. I'm, as you guys know, I'm a music nut. I'm like, absolute, and I think that that's a natural sort of a correlation between the two. It is, there's a, musicians are very funny. Yeah, they can be.
你知道的，这些年来，我遇到过很多非常非常热爱喜剧的乐队。我也认识很多非常非常热爱喜剧的乐队，同时我也认识很多非常热爱音乐的喜剧演员。就像你们知道的那样，我本人就是一个音乐狂热爱好者。我简直是狂热，而且我认为这两者之间存在着一种很自然的关联。确实如此，音乐家们通常都非常幽默。是的，他们确实可以很有趣。
Musicians really like to lay off. And some of the funniest people that I know are musicians and you know as funny as any professional comedians. So yeah, there's a connection there. There are many connections between comedy and music, timing, attention span, and music, timing, attention span, pitch, you know, I mean, think of, they used to call him the beast, you know who I mean? Sam. Sam Kelson? Yeah. Yeah. Sam Kelson. Think of his, think of how he made people laugh and the volume level that he was at, that he used as a commuting device and then think of someone like Stephen Wright, you know?
音乐家们真的很喜欢开玩笑。我认识的一些最搞笑的人恰好就是音乐家，而且他们搞笑的功力跟任何专业喜剧演员比起来都不遑多让。所以，是的，这两者之间确实存在联系。喜剧和音乐之间有很多相通之处：节奏、注意力持续时间，还有音高，你知道的，我是说，想想那个被他们称为“野兽”的人——你们知道我在说谁吗？Sam。Sam Kinison？对。对。Sam Kinison。想想他的表演，想想他是如何逗笑观众的，以及他在表演时那种高分贝的音量——他把音量当作一种喜剧工具，然后再想想斯蒂芬·赖特（Stephen Wright）那样的人，你知道吗？
So, so volume, yeah, there are a lot of connections. I mean, I also found a great affinity with painters. Some of my close friends were painters and the way they thought about how they resolved issues on a canvas was not very different from the way I thought about resolving questions that were of song questions. And you know what? I mean, a joltory is a friend of mine. And so is Bernie Williams. Wow. These the way they think about
所以，音量……是的，这里面有很多相通之处。我是说，我也发现自己和画家之间有着很深的共鸣。我的一些挚友就是画家，他们思考如何在画布上解决问题的方式，跟我思考如何解决歌曲中的那些疑问的方式并没有太大区别。你知道吗？安东尼·多特（Akil Baddoo，此处拼写疑为口误，或指某棒球手/艺术家）就是我的朋友。伯尼·威廉姆斯（Bernie Williams）也是。哇。他们思考
baseball and hitting, it wasn't any different from the way you guys are thinking about comedy and I'm thinking about music. It's like all of it is connected. Actually Paul, that's interesting because Bernie Williams is also a guitarist. Is there any musician as well? Yeah, very good guitarist. Good musician. Yeah, sound like a Yankee fan. We won't torture you and talk about this season, but there's always next year. Yeah, let's not bring up the subject this year. And Jason, why would you even mention it? He's a huge baseball fan. You know, they have made, go ahead. Go ahead, you talk here that you're the guest. I was just going for a second into how much I
棒球和击球的方式，跟你们思考喜剧、我思考音乐的方式简直如出一辙。这就好比万物皆有相通之处。说实话，保罗，这很有意思，因为伯尼·威廉姆斯也是个吉他手。他同时也是个音乐人吗？对，是个非常优秀的吉他手。是个好音乐人。听起来像个扬基队的球迷。我们今天就不拿这个来折磨你、谈论这个赛季了，不过明年还有机会嘛。对，今年咱们就别提这个话题了。杰森，你干嘛非要提这个？他可是个铁杆棒球迷。你知道的，他们做过……说吧，说吧。你来这儿做客，你先说。我刚才只是在想，我有多么
I like baseball and think about baseball and you know how much of my Identity has to do with baseball Like I'm I play guitar right-handed to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the to the ambidextrous. But sometimes if I go to as an exercise, go to a really, really pleasant memory from childhood. Go there, you know, as a meditation. A lot of them are baseball memories. And it's always Yankees never dodgers. No, no, it's no me playing. No Dodgers. No, I went to a Dodger game once when I was nine. My grandparents
喜欢棒球，脑子里经常想着棒球，你知道我的个人身份认同里有多少成分跟棒球息息相关吗？比如我弹吉他是用右手弹的……（此处语气词循环省略，直接过渡到下文）……我是左右开弓的。但有时候，如果我想做个练习，去回想一个来自童年非常非常愉快的记忆。作为一种冥想，回到那个记忆中去，你知道吗。其中很多都是关于棒球的记忆。而且永远都是扬基队，从来不是道奇队。不，不，那是我自己在打棒球的记忆。没有道奇队。我九岁的时候去看过一次道奇队的比赛。我外祖父母
lived in Brooklyn and they took me to Evans Field, but I wore a mask because they didn't want because they didn't want to be associated in any way. Wait, can I, Paul, can I read you this quote? Maybe you remember this quote from Donald Fagan. You know the quote I'm going to say about baseball. No, I don't, but I know I know Donald, but go ahead. Apparently he said that he described you as a certain kind of New York Jew, almost a stereotype really to whom music and baseball are very important.
住在布鲁克林，他们带我去了埃博茨球场（Ebbets Field），但我当时戴着口罩，因为他们不想……因为他们无论如何都不想跟道奇队扯上任何关系。等等，保罗，我可以给你念一段话吗？也许你还记得唐纳德·法根（Donald Fagen）说过的这段话。你知道我要说的是关于棒球的那段话吗？不，我不知道，但我确实认识唐纳德，不过你请说。他显然说过，他把你描述为某种特定类型的纽约犹太人——几乎可以说是一种刻板印象了——音乐和棒球对这类人来说至关重要。
I think it has to do with the parents. The parents are either immigrants or first generation Americans who felt like outsiders and assimilation was the key thought. They gravitated to black music and baseball looking for an alternative culture. And apparently upon hearing his description, you said that it isn't far from the truth. Yeah, I'll stick with that. Is there a question in there? No, no, I was just wondering. It's not just what I just wanted to say that.
我觉得这跟父母有关。父母要么是移民，要么是第一代美国人，他们感觉自己像局外人，而融入主流社会是当时的核心诉求。他们被黑人音乐和棒球所吸引，在其中寻找一种另类的文化。显然，在听到这种描述后，你说这离事实并不算太远。对，我承认这一点。这里面包含什么问题吗？没有，没有，我只是好奇。我只是想把这段话说出来。
No, I know. Are you a, are you, I would imagine, and I'm sure you're going to say, yes, just out of politeness, but I would imagine you'd be a pretty big Steely Dan fan. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Steely Dan is a very musical band, both of those guys. Well, it's only Donald now. Yeah, that was one of my favorites.
不，我懂。你是不是——我猜想，而且我敢肯定出于礼貌你一定会说是的——但我猜你很可能是 Steely Dan（钢筋丹）的超级大粉丝吧？对。对。对。Steely Dan 是一支音乐性极强的乐队，他们两个都是。嗯，现在只有唐纳德一个人了。对，那是我的最爱之一。
Do you feel like, do you still feel when you get up in the morning or right before you go to bed, or whenever you felt like when you were younger writing songs, do you still feel the same urge and pull? Like, if something inspires you, do you run and grab your guitar or sit at the piano or something like that to get it out before you forget or you just like, you know what, I'll get to it when I get to it now. Well now going to Seven Psalms, that idea came to me in a dream. A dream said, I can't remember whether it said you are
你有没有这种感觉：当你早晨醒来，或者在临睡前，或者每当你有像年轻时写歌时的那种感觉时，你是否依然能感受到那种强烈的冲动和牵引？比如，如果有什么东西激发了你的灵感，你会不会立刻跑去抓起你的吉他，或者坐在钢琴前，诸如此类的事情，赶在遗忘之前把它创作出来？还是说你会想：“你知道吗，等我有空的时候再去弄吧。”而现在，说到《Seven Psalms》（七首赞美诗），这个创意是我在梦中得到的。梦里说——我记不清它说的是你正在
working on a piece called Seven Psalms or you should write a piece called Seven Psalms. And it was such a strong dream that I got up and wrote it down. I don't, I don't usually, although I did the other day actually write something down. Now it's good that I do because otherwise I forget. But just because you wake up from a dream and write something down doesn't mean it's any good. Yeah. In fact, a lot of the stuff that you think up in your dreams is no good at all. Right.
创作一部名为《Seven Psalms》的作品，还是你应该写一部名为《Seven Psalms》的作品。这个梦是如此强烈，以至于我直接爬起来把它写了下来。我通常不会这样做，不过前几天我确实把一些东西写下来了。现在我这样做是对的，否则我很快就会忘光。但仅仅因为你从梦中醒来并把某些东西写下来，并不意味着它就一定好。对。事实上，你在梦中想出来的很多东西根本一点都不好。没错。
Especially funny stuff. Paul, have you ever been approached or been curious or interested in scoring movies? Do. Yeah, I am. I was going to get to. I haven't been approached too often, scoring movies? Do it. Yeah, I am. I was going to get to... I haven't been approached too often, but yeah, I am. I like it.
尤其是那些自以为很好笑的东西。保罗，你有没有曾经被邀请过，或者对为电影配乐感到过好奇或兴趣？有。是的，我有。我正要说到这儿。我没怎么经常接到电影配乐的邀请？干过这事。是的，我有。我很喜欢。
I would like the challenge of it. Yeah. All right, here come a bunch of people. Well, Jay, remember, he, Jay, remember, he, oh, sorry, I'm going to get into the movie thing because he worked with, obviously with Mike Nichols back in the day. Yeah, Mike asked us to do the, you know, to do the graduate. Yeah. Well, I was a big fan of Nichols and May. Yeah, for sure. Were you guys fans of Nichols and May? Oh, of course. Of course, yeah. Yeah.
我很喜欢这种挑战。好吧，这会儿来了一堆人。对了，杰伊，记住，他，杰伊，记住，他——哦，抱歉，我要扯到电影的事情上去了，因为他过去显然和迈克·尼科尔斯（Mike Nichols）合作过。对，迈克邀请我们去为……你知道的，为《毕业生》配乐。对。嗯，我当时是 Nichols and May（喜剧二人组）的超级粉丝。对，当然。你们当年也是 Nichols and May 的粉丝吗？哦，当然。当然是，对。对。
You know, it's, it's, it's, here's a, here's a question for you. It's an interesting dividing line. You know, you can find it in music, but you can find it in comedy too. There are certain comedians that you love. It's like when you when I said I your fans of Nichols and May, you all say, oh yeah, of course, you know, of course. Yeah. But that line, I wonder what that line means. Because if I said, did you, were you a big fan, were you all a big fan of Red Skelton? Yeah. See, there's, there are different kinds of humor, right? One, yeah, one's reality
你知道的，这、这、这，这里有一个问题要问你们。这是一条很有趣的分水岭。你不仅能在音乐中发现它，也能在喜剧中发现它。有些喜剧演员是你由衷喜爱的。这就好比刚才我说“你们是 Nichols and May 的粉丝”时，你们异口同声地说“哦对，当然，当然是”一样。但这条分水岭，我很好奇这条分水岭意味着什么。因为如果我说，你们当年都是雷德·斯克尔顿（Red Skelton）的超级大粉丝吗？对。你看，喜剧有不同的类型，对吧？一种，对，一种是基于现实的，一种是比较夸张的，对。
based, one's broad, yeah. Oh, that's interesting. I never, I never thought about how you would, what the different human, but you're humor, you know, when you were talking about how you would never want to be a dramatic actor, I was going to say that your humor is very I'd love to be a dramatic actor if I had the the ability but I don't yeah But what I'm here to tell you that you're doing it already be in your in your your your brand of comedy is very reality base It's very sort of dry. Yeah, it's dry. You're not you're not performing. You're not throwing to the back row. You're kind of in it and real and grounded. And that's a certain kind of humor, right? So it's Woody Allen humor versus Mel Brooks humor. Both great, but completely different. I don't mind would be the first comedic thing that I remember that I fell in love with was Bob and Ray. Did you ever hear
哦，真有意思。我以前从来没想过你会怎么去看待，不同的幽默形式到底……不过说到你的幽默——当你刚才谈到你绝不想当个正剧演员时，我本来想说你的幽默其实非常……如果我有那个能力的话，我很乐意去当个正剧演员，但我没有。不过我要告诉你的是，你其实已经在这么做了，在你的、你的、你的喜剧风格中，它是非常植根于现实的。它非常冷面、含蓄。对，它是冷面的。你不是在哗众取宠，你不是在迎合最后一排的观众。你整个人就沉浸在其中，真实而又接地气。这是一种特定类型的幽默，对吧？所以它就像是伍迪·艾伦式的幽默对阵梅尔·布鲁克斯（Mel Brooks）式的幽默。两者都很伟大，但完全不同。我不会介意……我记得我最早爱上的喜剧风格是 Bob and Ray（鲍勃与雷）。你们听说过
Bob and Ray? No. I've heard of them, but I don't know, Bob and Ray. Oh, well, you should you should do that because that's like, yeah, it's like me saying, did you, did you ever hear of Louis Armstrong, you know, if you're a Miles Davis, I can't have drunk a blank. That's the guy landed on the moon. Well, yeah, exactly what I thought Bob and Bob and Ray they were they were very deadpan. It was you know, by the way, Paul, you're not referring to you're not referring to Bob Ray, the former NDP premier of Ontario, right? He's that natural guy. Sorry. Oh, yeah, I mixed it up. Yeah, Bob Ray is. No Lord probably does. Yeah. Oh, yeah, I mixed it up. Yeah. Lord knows who Bob Ray is. No. Lord probably does. Yeah.
Bob and Ray 吗？没有。我听说过，但我不知道 Bob and Ray 是谁。哦，好吧，你们真该去了解一下，因为这就好比——这就好比我说“你们听说过路易斯·阿姆斯特朗吗”，如果你喜欢迈尔斯·戴维斯……我脑子里突然一片空白。那是那个登月的人吗？呃，对，这正是我在想的。Bob 和 Ray，他们的风格非常冷面。那是……顺便说一句，保罗，你指的不是安大略省前新民主党（NDP）省长鲍勃·雷（Bob Rae）吧？他是那种真人。抱歉。哦，对，我搞混了。对，鲍勃·雷是……上帝才知道谁是鲍勃·雷。不。上帝大概知道吧。对。
No. Well, you guys are in for a big, big treat when you rediscover Bob Elliott and Ray Goulding. They were incredible. I heard them on radio. I used to hear them in the morning before I was going to school. I guess my mother at least liked them. But it was the same kind of sort of school, not exactly because they were verbal, all verbal, but it was Jack Benny would be out of that world. It was a very dry kind of deadpan humor, which is a very close cousin to dramatic acting, you know, because you're
不。好吧，如果你们重新去发现鲍勃·埃利奥特（Bob Elliott）和雷·古尔丁（Ray Goulding）的魅力，那你们可真是有福了。他们太不可思议了。我以前在广播里听他们的节目。我上学前在早晨经常听。我想我母亲至少很喜欢他们。但那是一种同类型的、某种流派的幽默——虽然不完全一样，因为他们是纯语言类的，全靠嘴说——杰克·本尼（Jack Benny）的风格也脱胎于那个世界。那是一种非常冷面的、面不改色的幽默，它跟正剧表演其实是极其亲近的表亲，你知道的，因为你
not winking. You're trying to be real. You're not, you're not being goofy and winking to the audience. No, it's a wink more than Jason. No, it's a little. You're going to learn that again. I get hit for it. I think you know, it's not to be a name dropper, but I was having a conversation with Jack Nicholson once. Jesus Christ. How Paul is so tacky. Yeah, I'll tell you my biggest name-a-drop story in a second, but I was having this conversation with Jack Nicholson, and what I remember out of it was he said, at this point, I could play anything and get it right. I could play my mother and get it right.
不会给观众暗递眼色。你只是努力表现得真实。你不是在挤眉弄眼，不是在对观众使眼色。不，比杰森还要多一点使眼色。不，稍微有一点。你以后会知道的。我经常因此挨批。我想你知道的，这可不是为了故意掉书袋，但我有一次曾跟杰克·尼科尔斯（Jack Nicholson）聊天。天呐。保罗也太爱显摆了。对，我一会儿再跟你们讲我最大牌的掉书袋故事，但我当时正跟杰克·尼科尔斯聊着天，我从那次谈话中记住最深的一点是他说：到了我这个年纪，我可以演任何角色并且把它演对。我甚至可以演我妈并且把它演对。
So there's, for great actors, they have an ability to become something. I don't know how they do it. It seems like magic. It's like musicians where you say, how do you, how do they do that? Where'd that come from? It's, it's really a gift. It's a, it's really a gift. It's not, it's a great gift for those, you know. What's your, what's your biggest name drop story?
所以你看，对于伟大的演员来说，他们拥有化身为某种事物的能力。我不知道他们是怎么做到的。这简直就像是魔法。这就好比音乐家一样，你会忍不住问：“怎么会这样？他们是怎么做到的？这灵感是从哪儿来的？”这真的是一种天赋。这真的是一种天赋。这不仅仅是……对于那些人来说，这真是一份巨大的天赋。你最大牌的掉书袋故事是什么？
My biggest name drop story is, and it's not gonna, it's not gonna be what you think, because it's, it was, I was, I was talking to the Valley Lama. It's, that's not the name. Okay. That's still pretty big on this. But he said to me, he said, you know, I remember Mousetong once said to me, and he said, that's the best one.
我最大牌的掉书袋故事是——而且这绝对不会是你们猜的那样——因为当时，我当时正在跟达赖喇嘛交谈。这其实还算不上最大牌的名字。好吧。这其实已经挺大牌了。但他当时对我说，他说：“你知道吗，毛泽东有一次曾对我说……”然后他说了那句话，那绝对是最绝的。
I could, I could give you John Lennon, but I cannot, I cannot give you Mousetong. That's the best one. That's amazing. That's the best one ever. That's amazing. That's pretty good. Listen, I feel like we could talk to you all day. I do want to mention, because I think it's interesting to me, and I don't know if it resonates,
我可以跟你聊约翰·列农，但我绝对没法跟你聊毛泽东。这绝对是最绝的。这太牛了。这绝对是有史以来最绝的。这太厉害了。这相当厉害。听着，我觉得我们可以跟你聊上一整天。我确实想提一件事——因为我觉得这对我很有吸引力，我不知道这是否能引起共鸣，
or if there's any connection here, that hearing you talk about music and playing when you were young and you were saying to your dad had no influence, but I know that your dad was, because he was a musician, it sort of laid the groundwork for that to be part of, okay, to be part of your life or maybe how you got into it.
或者这其中是否存在某种联系——那就是听你谈论音乐，谈到你年轻时玩音乐，你说你父亲对你没有任何影响，但我知道因为你父亲本身就是个音乐家，这其实无形中为你的人生打下了基础，让你把音乐当作生活的一部分，或者说这可能是你走上音乐道路的方式。
And then now listen to Seven Psalms and your wife whom you mentioned is Edie is also participates on Seven Psalms. And I'm like, you've had a lifetime of making music and being around people who are family and people whom you've known forever. And what a great, again, I don't know if there's much of a question there,
而现在，听着《Seven Psalms》，你的妻子——也就是你刚才提到的 Edie——也参与了《Seven Psalms》的创作。我就在想：你经历了一生都在创作音乐，身边环绕的都是家人以及你认识了一辈子的人。这又是一次美妙的经历——再次说明，我不知道这其中有没有什么具体的问题，
but does that resonate at all with you? Well, it's a great privilege to make music with people whose music you respect. I'm married to a really great songwriter and singer, Edie Bracal. She sings two duets with me on the seven songs. But again, to go back to like these choices about where, you know, why would, how did you think of doing this thing or that unusual thing? It's about musicians. Like, it was strange for a little bit to be playing with musicians from South Africa,
但这是否能在你内心引起任何共鸣？嗯，能和那些你打心眼里尊重其音乐才华的人一起创作音乐，这绝对是一种巨大的特权。我的妻子埃迪·布里凯尔（Edie Brickell）是一位非常伟大的词曲作者兼歌手。她在《Seven Psalms》里和我一起合唱了两首二重唱。但话说回来，回到关于这些选择的问题上——你知道的，为什么会、你是怎么想到去做这件或者那件不寻常的事的？这一切都跟音乐家有关。比如，一开始和来自南非的音乐家们一起演奏感觉有点奇妙，
but it was just a little while, and then everything became just about the music. And then everything blended in and the differences evaporated for the moment. They never really go completely go away, but yeah, it's a cliche, but music is the universal language. It's true. Paul Simon, my gosh, I could listen to you. Paul, such an honor for you. I know.
但那种感觉只持续了一小会儿，然后一切就都只关乎音乐本身了。接着，所有的界限都融为一体，彼此之间的差异在那一刻烟消云散。它们其实从未真正完全消失，但——是的，这听起来是个陈词滥调，但音乐确实是全人类共同的语言。确实如此。保罗·西蒙，天呐，我真能听你讲一天。保罗，能采访你真是我们的荣幸。我知道。
You've taken some truly talk to us. It's truly a pleasure to meet you. Yeah. Thank you so much. I enjoyed it too. Yeah. Thank you, Paul. All right, guys.
你抽空跟我们聊了这么多。能见到你真的是莫大的荣幸。是的。非常感谢你。我也很享受这次对话。是的。谢谢你，保罗。好了，各位。
Thank you, Paul. What a pleasure. Thanks for having a great rest your day. Thank you, you as well. So you guys cool with me bringing Paul Simon on? Yeah, do we owe you any money for that? I mean, what the hell? I mean, I used to, you know, the lulla line. Cooosh.
谢谢你，保罗。真是太愉快了。祝你接下来的一天过得愉快。谢谢，也祝你们愉快。所以你们不介意我把保罗·西蒙请来吧？对，我们是不是还得为此付你出场费什么的？我的天哪，到底是怎么回事？我以前总是……你知道的，那句“la la la”。库什。
Is that the boxer? Is that that song? Yeah, I think so. I think that's right. I used to run around as a kid. By the way, I love you. Lulla line. Right?
那是《The Boxer》（拳击手）里的吗？是那首歌吗？对，我想是的。我想是这样的。我小时候经常到处跑。顺便说一句，我爱你。La la la。对吧？
Yeah. I used to pretend like I was doing those sounds. by the way I love you. La la la. Good. Right. Yeah. La la la la la. La la la. I used to pretend like I was doing those sounds myself for my hands. Sure. Oh, really with your hands. All alone in the backyard.
对。我以前经常假装自己用手就能发出那些声音。顺便说一句，我爱你。La la la la la。La la la。我以前甚至会假装那些声音是我自己用手打出来的。真的，用你的手。一个人孤零零地在后院里。
Oh, the sweet baby angel in the baby angel in the back. I wanted to recite the lyrics to baby driver on his way out, but I forgot. I mean, they're so... Did you know, do you remember the lyrics to Daddy Driver? Yeah, I guess you do. So all I know is, it was really fast. Will, can I, how do you, is it through Lauren that you know Paul? No, I don't know what it is.
哦，后院里那个像小甜心天使一样的小天使。我本来想在他离开的时候背诵一下《Baby Driver》的歌词的，但我给忘。我是说，它们的节奏太……你知道吗，你还记得《Baby Driver》的歌词吗？对，我想你肯定记得。所以我只知道，当时节奏真的超级快。威尔，我可以……你是通过洛伦（Lauren）才认识保罗的吗？不，我不知道这是怎么回事。
I don't know what it is. I don't know what it is it through Lauren that you know Paul? I don't know. I don't know what it is. I don't know at all through Lauren. And I just, I, I mean, they're very good friends, but I just, we just reached out and, you know, it's one of those kind of a long shot and you just hope that he responds. That's so crazy. You know, he's kind of like the, you know,
我不知道这是怎么回事。我不知道我是不是通过洛伦才认识保罗的？我不知道。我真的不知道。我根本不是通过洛伦认识的。我只是……我是说，他们俩是非常好的朋友，但我们当时只是试着去联系了一下，你知道的，这就像是一次胜算不大的盲目尝试，你只能祈祷他会回复。这太疯狂了。你知道的，他有点像是那种……
one of those icons where when he came onto the show just now and you're looking at him, you're like, wow, all those songs came out of his head. Yeah, do nuts. Dude, I was going through, like I said, I was going through it and I kept going like, oh yeah, 50 ways to leave your lever. Yeah.
那种标志性人物：刚才他一上节目，你看着他，心里就会想：“哇，所有那些伟大的歌曲竟然全都是从他脑子里蹦出来的。”对，简直疯狂。老兄，我刚才一直在回想，就像我说的，我脑子里一直闪过：“哦对，《50 Ways to Leave Your Lover》……”对。
Oh yeah, Bridget was a treble water. Oh yeah, sound of silence. Yeah, and like all this stuff he did, you know, he had, he had number one. Homeward bound, never homeward bound. Number one albums as, albums as both a band and a solo artist and number one, singlers as a band and a, so do you know how fucking rare that is? I know it's so rare.
哦是的，布里吉特是个高音水手。哦是的，寂静之声。是的，还有他做的所有这些事，你知道的，他曾有过，他有过第一名。Homeward Bound，从不Homeward Bound。作为乐队和个人都曾拥有过冠军专辑，作为乐队和个人也拥有过冠军单曲，你知道这有多他妈罕见吗？我知道，这太罕见了。
And my, you know, and Franny, 16 years old, she's listening to all, she's discovering, oh, hey, have you heard this song? Have you heard that I'm like, oh my god. Wow. Was the she, yeah. Yeah. I'm all the same. Oh, God. And so it brings me back when I'm like, oh my God. Wow. Was the shee, yeah. Yeah. There's so much. Oh, God.
还有我，你知道的，还有弗兰尼，16岁，她在听所有这些，她在探索，哦，嘿，你听过这首歌吗？你听过那个吗，我当时想，哦我的天哪。哇。是她吗，对。对。我都一样。哦，天哪。所以这让我想起了我还是个孩子的时候。我知道。那是个好主意。我很高兴你了解他。那太酷了。我本可以问他，你知道的，那么多问题。我只是想让他觉得无聊。我，你知道的，你总是发现自己，至少我发现自己，
So it brings me back to when I was a kid. I know. That's a good idea. I love that you got him well. That was so cool. I could have asked him like, you know, so many questions. I just want to bore him. I, you know, you always find yourself, at least I find myself,
当这样的人出现时，比如卡顿的手掌或什么的，你想问他所有粉丝的问题，但又不想显得像个混蛋。所以，你知道吗？是的。是的。我发现自己就像，你喜欢做的那样，你就像，其实不是一个问题，但我只是想
when somebody like that comes out, like, hand or palm of a carton, or something, you want to ask him all the fan questions, but you don't want to be a jerk about it. So, you know? Yeah. Yeah. I found myself like, you like to do, like, you're like, not really a question, but I just want
说，对，完全正确。对，我喜欢你。对，完全正确。对，完全正确。对，太……不，我觉得。你知道的，你知道这让我想到了什么，这是关于他所说的，这其实有点偏离主题，
to say, yeah, exactly. Yeah, I like you. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, it was so. No, I felt. You know, and you know what it made me think about this is, this is on what he was saying about, it's kind of off topic on this,
但那是关于杰克·尼科尔森的事情，杰克·尼科尔森说，顺便说一句，我认为杰克·尼科尔森是有史以来最伟大的演员之一，当然是电影演员，太棒了，我的意思是我是个超级粉丝。他说他现在可以演他的母亲，他什么都能做。我想，是的，你知道部分原因是什么吗？
but it was about the Jack Nicholson thing and Jack Nicholson saying, and by the way, I see I think Jack Nicholson, one of the greatest actors ever, certainly film actors, amazing, I mean massive fan. And he was saying that he could play his mother at this point, he could do anything. And I thought, yeah, and you know what part of it is?
这有点像保罗所说的，音乐奠定了基础，这样歌词才能传达出来。你买下了这种信誉。我认为杰克·尼科尔森多年来在文化上积累了如此多的信誉，所以我们知道他是谁。因此，如果一个外星人从外太空降临，他们可能不会欣赏他扮演他的母亲或做一些疯狂的事情，而我们会觉得，是的，但这是杰克·尼科尔森在演。
It's kind of like what Paul was saying about the music lays the groundwork so that the lyrics could then land. You buy that credibility. And I think Jack Nicholson has bought so much credibility over the years culturally, so we know who he is. So if an alien came down from outer space, they might not appreciate him playing his mother or doing something insane. The way that we would go, yeah, but it's Jack Nicholson playing this.
因为我们有一种内置的东西，他向我们倾注了50年的作品。他在这个观众身上积累了巨额的信誉。是的。他创作了《离开情人的50种方法》。是的。你知道，离开情人的方法之一就是说，再见！再见，利斯特！太快了，你回来了！再见！那是一个，那是一个直接说，再见！再见！太快了，你……
Because we have a built-in thing where he's laid 50 years of work on us. He's built so much bank with this audience. Yeah. He's done 50 ways to leave his lover. Yeah. You know, one way to leave your lover is just go, bye! Bye, Lister! So fast, you're back! Bye! That was a, that was a just go, bye! Bye! So fast, you're...
再见！那是一个，那是一个左勾拳，再见。哈哈哈哈！聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Bye! That was a, that was a left hook, bye. Ha ha ha! Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明Less是100%有机且由Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Umbjurf手工制作的。我们的下一集将在几天后在您收听播客的任何地方发布，或者您现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或Wondry应用程序中订阅Wondry Plus来提前收听并享受无广告服务。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umbjurf. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartLess 是由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Umbjurf 100% 有机手工制作的。我们的下一集将在四周后发布，无论你在哪里听播客都可以收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或 Wondry 应用中订阅 Wondry Plus 来提前收听且无广告。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。